bounce back a bounce back game
for shohei oh tony just get back here
with a lot of confidence that is going
to be the key word confidence today and
letting the baseball go
and springer goes down swinging and
there's out number one and now he can
record an era yeah
trying to bunt pops it up stassi makes
the catch two down
gregman shooting the first one out to
right field ward has to go back on and
mention with the heat that ball is going
to carry a nice first inning for shohei
oh tommy you see josh james on the mound
for the houston astros
called third strike 97 miles an hour
dotted up by josh james
make it 12 as a 97 mile an hour fastball
gets upton so two strikeouts and two
walks in the inning and now three and
one the count with albert pujols waiting
on deck
ground ball right side and eule will ask
james to cover and flip it to him for
the final hour ohtani has walked the
bases loaded with nobody out and that
one there is a swing and a foul tip it's
held by the catcher stacy struck him out
just what the doctor ordered fastball
got him looking 96 right down broadway
two down
here's the 3-2
and that is just inside ball four wow
brantley will score
and it is one to nothing astros that
pitch if it missed it was by a
fingernail ohtani not liking it either
conceivably could be the last batter and
a 3-1 count on springer
and yeah he's uh that's it i don't think
you can continue with him he does not
have the velocity right now and he
doesn't have the zone either that's five
walks in the inning so that's gonna be
it he gets a rather easy first inning
you're thinking all right here's a good
you know
talk about building blocks but uh kind
of fell apart in the second
that's an old-school taste right there
really is a little check swing towards
third bregman's gonna have to hurry he
does and retires
max stassi the former astro
on the little check swing ground ball on
the play ward loose the second
astros lead two to nothing on two bases
loaded walks
call third strike inside corner
josh james gets rendon looking for the
second out that is strikeout number four
for jj so albert is on the spot here
with the bases loaded the 2-0 delivery
and albert hits the ball way deep into
left field that's going to land in the
angel bullpen area that is a grand slam
for albert pujols
second home run now five rbi just two
home runs away from the say hey kid on
the home run list
he's looking over at us right now altuve
strikes out
two down
that's out toward right center field
goodwood moving back onto the track near
the wall and he will make the catch that
ball almost popped out of his glove
hold the right side this has it fires
over to short fletcher's there holby
milder on the return didn't get him
chris guccione says
he's right away milner saying check that
because he felt he stepped on the base
if he steps on the base he's got him
milner going to the base see if he steps
on it here
he's got it here comes the call
and he got all right nice play
swing and a miss
that's the curveball both strikeouts on
the breaking ball for frober there's one
away three 3-4-5 in the order for
houston beginning with bregman
hit to center field pretty well all the
way back goes goodwin this ball's gone
alex bregman the straightaway center
field
second home run of the year
and the astros back within one drummer's
allowed three hits
he's scattered them across
his three innings of work so far
as rendon sends one on the ground nice
play bregman to his left nice spinning
play on the throw as well bregman
retires the opposing third baseman for
the first down ball hit hard sunny day
that ball jumped a little bit but a nice
grab and able to make the adjustment on
the 360 move to give yulie a throw he
could handle here's the 01. curveball
grounded to the right side and it's cut
off by mayfield the shortstop and he
gets
goodwin by a half of a step a great play
by the astros shortstop to cut across
the astros have the tying run in scoring
position the go ahead run at first base
with one out and jose altuve coming up
tuva chops this one toward third rendon
fires to second base for one the relay
back not in time a nice play by this
coming off the base centers will be at
the corners two outs and breakman who
homer to lead off last inning for the
astros will be the next batter tube
takes off bregman chops this one toward
third backhanded by rondon off balance
throw and they get him he makes the stop
on that one and gets bregman but tree
comes in and keeps him off the
scoreboard for straw on second base and
now here's josh reddick
reddick with a base hit through the hole
on the left side straws gonna tie the
game four to four josh reddick the rbi
single
and for this second straight game the
astros have come from behind me tonight
stubbs sends one deep to left field this
will be deep enough to score tucker air
macio makes the catch he'll throw it all
the way in on the fly but no chance to
get tucker nice job by stubs on the sac
fly the astros have taken a 5-4 lead in
the 10.
back up the middle hits the mound correa
can't get it brendon's going to be waved
around here comes the throw from
springer to the plate not in time we are
tied up at five hermosillo the hero last
night picks up the single with two
strikes near the bottom of the tent so
one out springer's still at second for
bregman and bregman bounces it up the
middle and through for a base hit racing
around third and coming home is springer
he will score alex bregman with his
second rbi of the game and the astros
are on top six to five
fly ball
playable center field
george springer puts it away and the
astros are winners in 11 innings the
final score 6-5